The scale typically used to justify a movie's
success is the amount of money it earns at
the box office, and that's understandable.
If one movie earned more than another, that
means more people saw it.
But, that definitely doesn’t mean it’s
better.
Sometimes, truly terrific films flop hard
as far as the bean-counters are concerned.
Here are some of the best box office bombs.
Edge of Tomorrow
Without a proper marketing strategy that gets
butts in seats, movies can fail at the box
office — which is what happened to Doug
Liman's 2014 film Edge of Tomorrow, based
on Hiroshi Sakurazaka's novel All You Need
is Kill.
The trailers looked like just another generic
sci-fi flick, except this time with a bit
of Groundhog Day mixed in.
“What the hell?”
But Edge of Tomorrow is actually a whole lot
more than that.
It’s a sci-fi film that channeled D-Day
into a future war against an alien race with
the ability to reset the day.
That is until Tom Cruise comes along and breaks
their winning streak.
It’s basically a video game brought to live
action, in the best way possible.
Spawn, advance, die, repeat.
Despite great reviews, Edge of Tomorrow was
a box office dud.
And make no mistake, the bulk of the film's
failure hinged on its botched marketing campaign.
The studio basically retitled it Live.
Die.
Repeat when it was released on video.
If that doesn't scream bad marketing, nothing
does.
Dredd
Comic book movies are all the rage in Hollywood
these days, but that’s no guarantee for
success.
Dredd from 2012 is the perfect example.
Despite solid reviews from critics, it only
grossed $35.6 million against a $50 million
budget.
The film takes a few liberties with the source
material, but there's no denying it captures
the attitude of the comics pretty well.
It’s a brutal work of art, and the movie
that fans of the comics had waited decades
to see.
Plus, it features a motorcycle chase scene
that rivals The Matrix Reloaded.
That’s a pretty sweet bike, right?
Too bad it wasn't sweet enough to greenlight
a sequel...yet
"Negotiation's over."
Zodiac
The mystery of the Zodiac killer is a tale
that's arguably as intriguing and perplexing
as Jack the Ripper, which is why so many people
have tried to dramatize the story — including
David Fincher, who adapted Robert Graysmith's
crime book Zodiac for the big screen in 2007.
Laying out an extensive, in-depth case like
the Zodiac killer for a general audience is
difficult, but Fincher crafts a compelling
retelling of not only the murders, but also
the manhunt surrounding them.
"I'm not the Zodiac."
Couple that with a stellar cast that included
Robert Downey, Jr., Mark Ruffalo, and Jake
Gyllenhaal, and you've got a great drama.
Unfortunately, the film grossed just $84.8
million at the box office, but found new life
on home video, scoring profits of around $20
million.
Hugo
The director responsible for hard-R films
like Goodfellas, The Departed, and The Wolf
of Wall Street isn't exactly who you'd expect
to direct a PG movie, but Martin Scorsese
did a great job with the dramatic adventure
Hugo.
Hugo received stellar reviews from critics,
but that wasn’t enough to propel the movie
into box office glory.
It grossed almost $186 million worldwide against
an estimated production budget of $150 to
$170 million.
Although it failed to reach the box office
heights, Hugo is still a brilliant film and
a rare look into the rise of automation in
the early 20th century.
Scorsese blended steampunk elements into a
historical film with a Parisian backdrop — a
combination seldom seen in Hollywood, drawing
cues from A Trip to the Moon and The Impossible
Voyage rather than modern superhero flicks.
And that's what makes it beautiful.
The Road
Based on the novel of the same name by Cormac
McCarthy, The Road was released in 2009 and
grossed a mere $27.6 million against a $25
million production budget.
But the fact that the film made it out at
all is a miracle.
Anyone who's read a McCarthy novel knows how
difficult they are to translate onto the silver
screen.
Seriously, it’s just a whole lot of that.
How do you show audiences that the film they're
watching is set in a post-apocalyptic world?
Simple: make everything dark and gray.
There's rarely been a more haunting representation
of a post-apocalyptic world, and that's why
this film is so important to the genre.
It isn't about why the world is the way it
is.
Instead, it’s about the father-son relationship
of the main characters.
Sure, it might be bleak, but it’s a story
well worth seeing.
Master and Commander: The Far Side of the
World
Based on Patrick O'Brian's naval novel, Master
and Commander was meant to be a war movie
blockbuster.
Unfortunately for Russell Crowe, who starred
in the often forgotten film, it was released
the same year as the cartoonish, non-war blockbuster,
Pirates of the Caribbean: The Curse of the
Black Pearl, which introduced Johnny Depp's
Captain Jack Sparrow to the world.
Turns out, there wasn’t enough room for
two adventures on the high seas.
“I’m Captain jack Sparrow”
But forget all that junk.
Master and Commander is a feast for the eyes,
depicting an often forgotten period of European
history, and it does so remarkably well.
Unlike many other historical dramas, it gets
the real-life details mostly right.
And Crowe brings it all home with his exceptional
performance.
The fact that the film received a whopping
ten Oscar nominations underscores its excellence,
and legendary film critic Roger Ebert gave
the film a rare perfect score, saying "it
achieves the epic without losing sight of
the human.”
Speed Racer
The Wachowskis made a name for themselves
by writing and directing The Matrix trilogy.
When it came time for them to tackle a new
project, they chose to bring the classic Speed
Racer series to life on the big screen.
With the Wachowskis at the helm and the name
recognition of the property, it was a shock
to see Speed Racer flop at the box office,
grossing $93.9 million on a budget of $120
million.
"Whoa."
The film's cartoonish visuals may have turned
off some critics, but for franchise fans,
it was exactly what the film needed to capture
the awe of the original anime.
What's interesting, though, is that the movie
includes themes of politics and corruption,
as well as general issues in society, and
those themes unfold on a number of levels.
Yet it never forgets that it's still a kids'
movie.
Speed Racer didn't fall into the trend of
gritty re-imaginings that plagued the 2000s.
Instead, it takes a funny, witty, and light-hearted
charm that’s exactly what fans wanted.
It’s just too bad more people didn’t see
it.
The BFG
Steven Spielberg ranks among the greatest
living filmmakers, and the fact that he's
the highest-grossing director of all time
only bolsters his legacy.
He's the guy that pretty much created the
summer blockbuster, after all.
But none of that helped The BFG gross more
than $183.2 million worldwide on an estimated
$140 million budget in 2016.
The movie was a recipe for success.
It was directed by Spielberg, distributed
by Disney, and is based on the famed Roald
Dahl novel of the same name.
So why it failed to break $200 million is
a mystery.
Monetary problems aside, The BFG is a criminally
underrated film.
Despite its big budget, fantastical elements,
and summer release, it was still far from
your traditional summer tentpole.
Basically, it was a big-budget fantasy, without
the extravaganza.
It's not so much about the spectacle as it
is about the journey, and that's where audiences
will find themselves captivated by Mark Rylance's
outstanding motion-capture performance as
well as the irresistible charm of Hollywood
newcomer Ruby Barnhill.
Do yourself a big favor and check out The
BFG, ASAP.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!